>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," KANYE WEST, NOW KNOWN
AS YE IS ONE OF THE BEST-SELLING
MUSICAL ARTISTS IN THE WORLD,
CELEBRATED AND VERY HIGHLY PAID
FASHION DESIGNER.
FOR DECADES HE WAS WELL-KNOWN TO
TV AUDIENCES AS A IN LAW OF THE
KARDASHIAN FAME.
IT WAS HIS LATEST INCARNATION AS
A CHRISTIAN EVANGELIST THAT
BROUGHT US TO HIS OFFICE FOR THE
INTERVIEW YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE.
DAYS AGO DURING FASHION WEEK
WEST ACCOMPANIED BY HIS FRIEND
CANDACE OWENS UNVEILED A T-SHIRT
THAT SAID SIMPLY "WHITE LIVES
MATTER" THE RESPONSE FROM THE
FASHION INDUSTRY WAS
INSTANTANEOUS AND UNIFORM.
SHOCK, HORROR, RAGE.
THERE WAS NO EXCUSE FOR THIS
FUND OR "THE NEW YORK TIMES," HE
IS LEGITIMIZING EXTREMISM, TREAT
ROLLING STONE.
WHAT WAS MISSING FROM THE
COVERAGE WAS AN EXPLANATION FOR
WHY HE DID THIS, WHAT WAS THE
T-SHIRT ABOUT?
AND NO ONE SEEMED TO THINK TO
ASK HIM MUCH LESS LISTEN TO WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY.
THE ENEMIES OF IDEAS DISMISSED
WEST AS THEY HAVE FOUR YEARS AS
MENTALLY ILL, TOO CRAZY TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY.
LOOK AWAY, IGNORE HIM, HE'S A
MENTAL PATIENT -- NOTHING TO SEE
HERE.
IS HE CRAZY?
YOU CAN JUDGE FOR YOURSELF AS
YOU WATCH WHAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
SHOW YOU.
HE HAS HIS OWN IDEAS, WE CAN SAY
THAT -- CREATIVE PEOPLE TEND TO
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ARTISTS NOT
ACTUARIES PERIODS SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS GIVE THE IMPRESSION OF A
MAN CHANNELING HIS RAWEST
EMOTIONS RIGHT ON INSTAGRAM.
IT'S OFTEN USED AS AMMUNITION
AGAINST HIM IN THE BATTLE FOR
INFLUENCES OVER AMERICA'S YOUNG
PEOPLE.
BUT CRAZY?
THAT WAS NOT OUR CONCLUSION.
WE HAVE RARELY HEARD A MAN >> SO
HONESTLY AND SO MOVINGLY ABOUT
WHAT HE BELIEVES.
AGAIN, YOU CAN JUDGE FOR
YOURSELF -- HERE IS.
YOU JUST CAME FROM PARIS FASHION
WEEK, WHAT IS THAT?
>> IS A PHOTOGRAPH OF A BABIES
ULTRASOUND?
>> Tucker: YOU DESIGN THAT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT REPRESENTS LIFE, I'M
PRO-LIFE.
>> Tucker: YOU WEAR IT ON A
BADGE, WHAT KIND OF RESPONSE DO
YOU GET?
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE
RESPONSE AS I CARE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE IS MORE BLACK
BABIES BEING ABORTED THEN BORN
IN NEW YORK CITY AT THIS POINT.
50% OF BLACK DEATH IN AMERICA IS
ABORTION.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE'S
RESPONSE, I PERFORM FOR AN
AUDIENCE OF ONE AND THAT IS GOD.
>> Tucker: I'M STARTING TO SEE
WHY THEY WANT TO MAKE YOU BE
QUIET.
WHEN DID YOU START TO FEEL THIS
WAY, WHEN DID YOU REALIZE THIS?
>> I THINK I STARTED TO REALLY
FEEL THIS NEED TO EXPRESS MYSELF
ON ANOTHER LEVEL WHEN TRUMP WAS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND I LIKED
HIM.
HIM AND EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
HOLLYWOOD FROM MY EX-WIFE TO MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW TO MY MANAGER AT
THAT TIME TO MY SO-CALLED
FRIENDS AND HANDLERS AROUND ME
TOLD ME THAT IF I SAID I LIKED
TRUMP THAT MY CAREER WOULD BE
OVER, MY LIFE WOULD BE OVER.
THEY SAID STUFF LIKE PEOPLE GET
KILLED FOR WEARING A HAT LIKE
THAT, THEY THREATENED MY LIFE.
THEY BASICALLY SAID I WOULD BE
KILLED FOR WEARING THE HAT.
I HAD SOMEONE CALL ME LAST NIGHT
AND SAID ANYBODY WEARING A WHITE
LIVES MATTER SHIRT IS GOING TO
BE GREEN LIT AND THAT MEANS
THEY'RE GOING TO BEAT THEM UP IF
THEY WEAR IT.
I'M LIKE GREEN LIGHT NEEDED TO.
GOD BUILDS WARRIORS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BECAUSE OF
ME BEING BORN IN ATLANTA AND
GROWING UP ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO, HE MADE ME FOR SUCH A
TIME LIKE THIS.
IT'S LIKE WITH DAVID.
HE TENDED TO THE SHEEP BUT WHILE
HE WAS OUT THERE HE HAD TO FIGHT
ALL KINDS OF ANIMALS.
WHEN IT WAS TIME FOR GOLIATH TO
COME HE THOUGHT BECAUSE HE WAS A
SHEEPHERDER THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE SKILL SET TO TAKE DOWN
GOLIATH AND THE THING THAT I
HAVE SOME OF THE POSITION THAT I
HAVE, MY HEART -- BUT THE NUMBER
ONE THING IS WE HAVE GOD ON OUR
SIDE.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
GOD, GOD BELIEVES IN YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU MADE REFERENCE
TO THE WHITE LIVES MATTER
T-SHIRT WHICH YOU BROUGHT OUT AT
PARIS FASHION WEEK.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT AND WHAT DID
IT MEAN?
>> I DO CERTAIN THINGS FROM A
FEELING, I JUST CHANNEL THE
ENERGY IT FEELS RIGHT.
HITS USING A GUT INSTINCT,
CONNECTION WITH GOD AND JUST
BRILLIANCE.
THEY ASKED TONYA HARDING HOW SHE
DID THE TRIPLE FLIP AND SHE WAS
IN SO MUCH PRACTICE THAT WHEN IT
WAS TIME FOR HER TO SKATE IN A
COMPETITIVE FORMAT IT JUST
HAPPENED.
IT HAPPENED OUTSIDE OF PRACTICE
THAT HAPPENED IN THE REAL
FORMAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
GOD IS PREPARING US FOR THE REAL
BATTLES.
WE ARE IN A BATTLE WITH THE
MEDIA.
THE MAJORITY OF THE MEDIA HAS A
GODLESS AGENDA AND THEY ARE LIKE
YE IS CRAZY -- THEY DON'T WORK
BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAVE ALSO
WATCHED TRAVESTIES HAPPEN, EVEN
SPECIFICALLY TO ME.
JUST WATCH IT AND ACT LIKE IT
WASN'T HAPPENING AND THEY STAY
QUIET ABOUT IT.
I WANT TO ANSWER -- I FEEL LIKE
SOMEONE CALLED WHAT I WAS SAYING
THE COMPARISON OF TONYA HARDING
TO WHITE LIVES MATTER.
MY DAD IS AN EDUCATED
EX-BLACK PANTHER AND HE PUT A
TEXT TO ME TODAY AND HE SAID
WHITE LIVES MATTER, HAHAHA.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY, THE IDEA
OF ME WEARING IT WAS FUNNY AND I
SAID WHY DO YOU THINK IT'S
FUNNY?
AND HE SAID JUST A BLACK MAN
STATING THE OBVIOUS.
MY DAD DOESN'T LISTEN TO RAP
MUSIC, HE'S SUPER EDUCATED, WE
OPENED UP A WATER DISTRIBUTION
CENTER IN THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC
TOGETHER.
HE'S LIKE THE ORIGINAL
STEVE JOBS.
BUT HE WAS GETTING BLOCKED EVERY
WHICH WAY WITH ALL OF HIS IDEAS
AND HE DIDN'T HAVE AN ENDLESS
BANK ACCOUNT AND HE DIDN'T HAVE
INSTAGRAM, ALL THESE IDEAS HE
HAD TO TAKE THEM BACK AND
COMPRESS THEM.
MY DAD IS THE MOST BRILLIANT
PERSON THAT I KNOW AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A STRAINED
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE I WAS TAKEN
FROM HIM BECAUSE MY MOM WAS AN
ACTRESS SO SHE WAS A LIBERAL.
MY DAD WOULD SEE CERTAIN THINGS
AND SAY WE SHOULD DO IT THIS
WAY, WE SHOULD DO IT THAT WAY
AND THE PEOPLE AROUND MY MOM AND
PULLED HER AWAY MUCH LIKE KIM IS
A CHRISTIAN BUT SHE HAS PEOPLE
WHO WANT HER TO GO TO INTERVIEW
MAGAZINE AND PUT HER ASS OUT
WHILE SHE'S A 40
SOMETHING-YEAR-OLD BILLIONAIRE
WITH MULTIPLE BLACK CHILDREN AND
THAT'S HOW THEY WANT TO PRESENT
HER.
YOU GIVE YOU THESE QUESTIONS AND
I GIVE YOU THE THREE-PART
ANSWERS, IS THIS A COOL FORMAT
FOR YOU?
>> Tucker: I AM FOLLOWING YOU.
YOU SAID YOUR FATHER SAID IT'S
GREAT TO SEE A BLACK MAN STATING
THE OBVIOUS.
BY WHICH I THINK YOU MEANT
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY TRUE.
>> THAT WAS MY FAVORITE RESPONSE
BECAUSE I KEPT THINKING, PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR AN EXPLANATION
AND PEOPLE SAY AS AN ARTIST YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GIVE AN
EXPLANATION BUT AS A LEADER YOU
DO.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT.
SPEAK OF THE ANSWER TO WHY I
WROTE WHITE LIVES MATTER ON A
SHIRT IS BECAUSE THEY DO.
IT'S THE OBVIOUS THING.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT'S -- I
ASSUME THE IMPLICATION, ALL
LIVES MATTER BECAUSE THEY ARE
LIVES AND GOD CREATED THEM, WHY
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED CONTROVERSIAL?
>> BECAUSE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
HAVE STRIPPED US OF OUR IDENTITY
AND LABELED US AS A COLOR HAVE
TOLD US WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
BLACK.
IN THE VERNACULAR THAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
MY DAD GREW UP AS A MILITARY
BRAT AND HIS FAMILY MOVED AROUND
BUT THEY ARE BASED MOSTLY IN
DELAWARE AND AT THE TIME, IF
THEY WEREN'T THE ONLY BLACK
FAMILY, THEY WERE ONE OF THE
FEW.
HE WOULD BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST BECAUSE HE WAS BLACK, BY
THE TIME HE GOT INTO COLLEGE HE
WOULD BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST,
HE WENT TO A BLACK COLLEGE, HE
WOULD BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
BECAUSE THEY SAID HE TALKED TO
WHITE AND THEN HE PLAYED THE
KICK DRUM IN THE BAND, WHEN HE
WOULD GO TO THE CLUB AND THE
MUSIC WAS PLAYING WHERE HE
CLAPPED HIS HANDS?
WITH THE KICK DRUM -- IS THE
OPPOSITE OF EVERYONE ELSE.
THIS IS THE MOST ELEGANT AND
TASTEFUL PERSON THAT I KNOW AND
WHEN THE SCHOOL SUGGESTED --
WHAT THEY DO IS TAKE THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND THEY SEPARATE US,
THEY SEPARATE THE FAMILIES AND
THE EDUCATED, THEY PUSH THIS
NEED FOR HIGHER EDUCATION, US AS
BLACKS WE DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND SAY I GOT MY
PhD YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR PhD
I'M BETTER THAN YOU.
MY MOM HAD HER PhD AND SHE WAS
INFLUENCED TO MOVE TO THE SOUTH
SIDE OF CHICAGO, TAKE THIS JOB
AT CHICAGO STATE UNIVERSITY SHE
TOLD MY DAD IF YOU COME FOR US
YOU WILL NEVER SEE HIM AGAIN.
THE MEDIA RIDICULED ME FOR
GETTING THE HOUSE NEXT DOOR TO
KIM TO SEE MY CHILDREN AND THEY
EVEN SAID I WAS STALKING HER AND
HER NEW BOYFRIEND BECAUSE I
BOUGHT THE HOUSE NEXT DOOR TO
SEE MY CHILDREN.
THAT'S HOW I KNEW MY MOM HAD
SAID THAT TO HIM, I SAID THEY
MOVED US TO ONE OF THE MOST --
AGREED UPON TO BE ONE OF THE
MOST DANGEROUS PLACES IN THE
WORLD.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY TRIED TO
KILL ME OR SOMETHING.
I SAID WHY DIDN'T YOU EVER COME
TO GET US?
THAT'S WHEN HE TOLD ME THAT SHE
WAS TOLD THAT.
SO MANY THINGS ARE PUT IN KIM'S
HEAD TO.
BRING INFLUENCERS LIKE NO ONE
EVER KNEW WERE CORY GAMBLE CAME
FROM, NO ONE KNOWS WHERE HE CAME
FROM -- THESE PEOPLE WERE
PRACTICALLY MADE IN A LABORATORY
IN MY OPINION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY'RE REALLY
GOOD AT DOING IS BEING NICE AND
BEING LIKABLE.
WHAT THEY DO IS FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SOME FORM OF INFLUENCE
WHETHER IT'S AN EDUCATED BLACK
WOMAN LIKE MY MOTHER THAT BECAME
THE HEAD OF THE ENGLISH
DEPARTMENT AT CHICAGO STATE
UNIVERSITY OR WHETHER IT'S THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL WHITE WOMAN ON
THE PLANET BEING MY EX-WIFE,
THEY HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE AROUND
THEM AT ALL TIMES TELLING THEM
WHAT TO BE AFRAID OF.
NOT WHAT TO DO OR SAY, WANT TO
BE AFRAID OF AND IF YOU HAVE A
PERSON THAT ISN'T AFRAID OF
THEM -- LIKE RUSSELL BRAND OR
CANDACE OWENS -- IS NOT THAT WE
HAVE TO AGREE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE NOT
AFRAID.
>> THEY AREN'T AFRAID TO STATE
WITH HER OPINION IS.
EVERYONE HAS AN OPINION.
>> Tucker: A CONVERSATION LIKE
THIS IS A WINDOW INTO A WORLD
THAT YOU DON'T SEE, SO IF YOU
ARE FAMILIAR WITH WEST FROM THE
MEDIA, YOU THINK OF HIM AS AN
INDIVIDUAL MAN.
WHAT YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT IS
THAT HE IS AT THE CENTER OF A
BATTLE AND PEOPLE LIKE HIM ARE
AT THE CENTER OF A BATTLE TO GET
A MESSAGE OUT.
MOUTH BY THE LIPS OF INFLUENCERS
LIKE HIM AND SO MANY OTHERS THAT
EXTENDS A STORY LINE ON BEHALF
OF THE STATUS QUO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE VYING
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT PEOPLE LIKE
HIM SAY THE RIGHT THINGS.
THE CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT DOING
THAT ARE SEVERE.
FOR HIM TO COME OUT AND SAY ALL
LIVES MATTER OBVIOUSLY IS A HUGE
THREAT TO A LOT OF PEOPL